wir wohnen jetzt seit vier Monaten auf
unserem neuen Bauernhof und die einzigen
Tiere die wir bisher haben sind drei
kleine Hühnchen nichts für ungut aber
ich habe mir das Bauernhofleben eher so
vorgestellt wir haben zwar gerade 25
Eier im Brutautomaten um uns eine
richtig tolle große Hühnerschar
aufzubauen aber ich finde es ist an der
Zeit dass endlich auch ein paar größere
Bauernhoftiere hier einziehen heute
bereiten wir den Stall weiter vor äh
habe ich gesagt um welches Tier es sich
handelt
entschuldigung das könnte euch so passen
ich verrate euch noch nicht welches Tier
einzieht es ist lustigerweise ein Tier
geworden von dem ich mir geschworen habe
dass ich es niemals haben will mal
gucken wer von euch errätt welches es
ist als wir uns überlegt haben wo der
Stall hin soll war ziemlich schnell klar
dass es dieser Teil der Scheune werden
wird weil das der einzige Ort ist von
dem aus die Tiere selbständig in den
Garten gehen können und in den Stall
gehen können ohne dass ich sie morgens
und abends rein und rausführen muss hier
liegt aber noch ganz viel altes Holz
dass wir erstmal kleinsägen müssen damit
wir es entweder verbrennen können oder
ins Morgen wenn es z.B lackiert ist
damit die leichter hier vom Stall in
Garten kommen obwohl es hier so eine
Steigung gibt bauen wir den jetzt na
[Musik]
Rampe
die Rampe ist ganz schön steil geworden
wenn die Tiere da sind müssen wir mal
gucken ob wir die vielleicht noch
flacher umbauen müssen wir haben hier
jetzt festgestellt dass von der Wand
ganz viel von diesem grauen Putz oder
was das ist abröckelt und damit sich das
nicht mit unserem Mist vermischt ich
noch besser Werkzeug suchen tatsächlich
ja mach das mal in der Werkstatt auf
jeden Fall wollen wir verhindern dass
ich das hier mit nach und nach mit dem
Mist vermischt weil ich den ja im Garten
verwenden möchte dann kom postiert und
dann mag ich nicht sowas drin haben
deswegen machen wir das was jetzt wieso
hier schnell abpreln würde einfach mal
von der Wand ab und sammeln das vorher
[Musik]
ein wir haben erst gedacht wir kaufen
Bretter im Baumarkt aber dann haben wir
hier diese richtig coolen alten Bohlen
gefunden und daraus bauen wir jetzt hier
den Zaun hier bauen wir ein Tor rein
auch aus den gleichen Bohlen hier kommt
der Zaun noch wirer fertig
gebaut und hier hinten ist die Mauer
noch ein bisschen kaputt und das müssen
wir neu Mauern wir haben zum Glück noch
ein paar von diesen Steinen und ich habe
noch nie gemauert aber es wird schon
irgendwie so stabil werden dass die das
nicht gleich Eindrücken und dahinter
sieht man auch lagert ganz viel Stroh
das können wir gleich hier rüber
schaffen und damit den Stall
[Musik]
einstreuen ja das ist zwar die
stimperhafteste Mauer überhaupt geworden
aber was soll sie hält und wir müssen
uns jetzt beeilen mit den letzten
Aufräumarbeiten weil wir nämlich gleich
losgehen und die Tiere abholen ich bin
so
[Musik]
aufgerägt dafür müssen wir erstm ein
Mietwagen holen weil die hier in unser
kleines Auto auf jeden Fall nicht
reinpassen so seid ready ja wir sind
ready wir haben jetzt hier den Mietwagen
wir haben gesehen hier ist noch
Teppichboden hinten drin damit hatten
wir nicht gerechnet deswegen müssen wir
noch mal nach Hause fahren um da
irgendwas reinzulegen
falls falls die Tiere dort irgendwie
reinpinkeln sollten na was könnte das
für ein Tier sein dessen Po gerade in
meinem Gesicht
[Musik]
ist
ja es sind Schafe geworden die ein oder
anderen mögen sich daran erinnern dass
ich 15 Jahre lang Ziegen und Schafe
gehalten habe und ich habe das ein oder
andere mal Sachen gesagt wie Ziegen sind
so viel intelligenter Ziegen sind so
viel charismatischer die haben irgendwie
so viel mehr Scham als Schafe Schafe
sind schon ein bisschen dümmlicher es
tut mir leid dass ich so schlecht über
euch geredet habe aber wieso habe ich
dann Schafe gekauft wir haben hier bei
uns im Garten ganz viele Obstbäume alle
möglichen Sachen birnenäpfel
zetsch also wir haben fast alles was was
man sich so wünschen könnte und so schön
das ist aber Ziegen könnte man in so
einem Garten nur sehr schlecht halten
weil Ziegen super gerne Zweige fressen
und bei diesen halbstämmen die Äste ja
teilweise fast bis auf dem Boden hängen
das heißt bis auf eine Höhe von 2 m
werden die komplett abgefressen und das
würde einfach nicht funktionieren ich
habe auch überlegt Kühe zu halten weil
ich eben super gerne melken möchte und
unsere eigenen Milchprodukte herstellen
aber für Kühe ist der Garten irgendwie
leider ein bisschen zu klein und
Schafsmilch ist auch so der Champagner
unter den Milcharten ne also Schafsmilch
ist so reichhaltig und so gesund es tut
mir immer noch ein bisschen weh weil ich
Ziegen halt so vermisse ich habe seit
einem Jahr keine Ziegen mehr weil ich
die abgeben musste weil da jemand auf
der
Weide mehrere Ziegen getötet hat und das
einfach nicht mehr sicher war und ein
ganz großer Grund warum ich diesen
Bauernhof hier gekauft habe war dass ich
meine Tiere unbedingt am Haus haben
möchte nicht mehr so weit weg wie früher
früher hatte ich ganz viele ute kleine
Grundstücke und das Schöne ist die
beiden sind prächtig das heißt im
Frühling kommen Lämmer auf die Welt das
heißt dass wir ab späten Frühjahr wenn
die lämer schon ein bisschen größer sind
anfangen können zu melken ich werde die
nicht von ihren Müttern trennen erst
wenn sie alt genug sind um verkauft zu
werden dann werden wir die lämer
eventuell abgeben vielleicht behalten
wir auch noch eins weil man von scharfen
eigentlich eher drei halten sollte als
zwei als Mindestanzahl dann werde ich
die Lemma über Nacht
von den Müttern so trennen dass sie sich
noch sehen können weil ich das immer so
schrecklich finde wenn man Milch kauft
und das ist ein großer Grund für mich
meine eigenen Milchprodukte herstellen
zu wollen aber dann werden ja den
Müttern die Kinder direkt nach der
Geburt oder kurz nach der Geburt
entrissen die Tiere fühlen ja nicht
weniger für ihre Kinder nur weil sie
Tiere sind dieser Instinkt ist ja der
gleiche dass das Wichtigste im Leben der
eigene Nachwuchs ist und mir ist es
total wichtig dass die lämer mit ihren
Müttern zusammen aufwachsen deswegen
habe ich das immer so gemacht dass ich
die übernacht getrennt habe so dass sie
sich aber immer noch sehen können dann
habe ich am Morgen ein bisschen was von
der Milch abgemolken und den Rest des
Tages sind die dann wieder zusammen im
Garten rumgelaufen und wenn die Lämmer
dann groß genug sind werde ich zweimal
am Tag melen aber vorher muss ich mich
mit den Mädels natürlich erstmal seit
anfreunden dass die mich sie überhaupt
anfassen lassen aber dafür haben wir ja
jetzt noch genug
[Musik]
Zeit